hey man are we recording yeah we've been
recording for a while
yeah i'm so sorry i'm late man i um as
you know we've got pigs here at the
house and uh my wife is
out of town yeah two pigs two pigs yeah
two people
with two pigs we got two pigs two dogs
two guinea pigs
um my wife also has a donkey a zonkey
and three horses
so uh we're contributing to the uh
livestock and animal husbandry
basically living in a zoo essentially
essentially
living in a zoo well you know
part of me is like that's cool yeah
because look at you
you know one with nature right
surrounding yourself
with uh made up animals like zonkeys
which we all know is fake there's no
such thing
genetic engineering at the same time
like is that a
is that a good idea is that like a good
idea to have you know a bunch of
animals living in a kind of urban
environment
i mean what do they eat like doritos and
stuff no they eat animal mush i think
it's good it makes me feel at one with
nature although
you're right i mean there are some moral
questions it's like is this really the
very best place for these pigs to be
living
i mean it's certainly better than a than
a bacon farm
you know in nebraska but uh it does
but do you do you have animals or you
you've got livestock or
what do you have this is the thing like
yeah we have we have uh we have chickens
uh but you know i kind of the reason i'm
asking this is because i
sort of went underwent a kind of a moral
quandary myself my wife and i who are
big bee lovers right we're very stressed
out about you know
a possible future without bees which i
guess is a very real possibility
and so we had this idea as stupid people
do where we thought well maybe we can
you know control
the the problem in some way we can
uh you know benefit the bee population
we'll raise our own bees so like we
literally went out there like we got a
big hive
and we put it all together and we got
all the equipment we don't know [ __ ]
about bees but we read a book
um and went out and got uh
12 000 bees that we had every intention
of you know of caring for and raising
and like you know
helping to boost uh
the world i have so many questions about
the 12 000 bees did you interview them
we did we we we were only going to take
like the best b's like we're not going
to take
subpar b's how do you know you had 12
000 how did you know it's not like
3 700 bees and why do they come in
batches of 12 000
we were just told there were 12 000 in
the in the box and i guess we just took
the guy's word for it
you know it's not like in those movies
where like they give you the money and
and you're like i'm just going to count
this real quick that's 1b
that's like the population of olympia
washington
well we ended up
accidentally killing the population of
olympia washington
like that's the moral of this story is
that everything that we tried to do
we actually ended up having our colony
collapse so like we
far from trying to save the bees we we
took part in their inevitable
destruction oh my god that's terrible
be killer but this is the problem right
like when you
when you insert yourself into nature it
doesn't matter whether you have like you
know
the best of intentions which we did you
know
chances are because we're humans and
we're [ __ ] morons that we're
gonna screw it up in in some way that's
why i'm worried about your pigs is what
i'm trying to say
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake my pigs are fine i'm
not going to kill my pigs and i'm not
going to let
harm come to them but you know this
this issue man's harmony with nature man
changing nature controlling nature is at
the heart
of a new book uh written by elizabeth
colbert
she's the author of uh field notes from
a catastrophe man nature and climate
change she won the pulitzer
just a couple years ago for her book the
sixth extinction great book and she's
got a new book under a white sky
the nature of the future so i'm so
excited to talk to her
about what the nature of the future
actually is
yeah the book is about how maybe
the answer to dealing with our
catastrophic attempts to control nature
is more control of nature which
brings up all kinds of you know issues
like is this the right thing to do
i mean how can you trust human beings
are we just going to kill the bees that
we're trying to
to save and but you know it's an
important question you and i we you and
i
take you know the environment seriously
we try our best to be
good stewards of the earth but yes
it does it means something different now
to be a steward
of the earth so many so many questions
to ask
elizabeth colbert she's a staff writer
at the new yorker
she's received two national magazine
awards
uh and as you mentioned the pulitzer
which um i guess is an important
award it's a little important received
one but you know this issue is not as
cut and dry as like oh let's be good to
planet earth
we've already taken it up to the brink
and we've meddled with it so very much
like reza and his bees
uh it becomes a very complicated
variegated nuanced uh
and incredibly relevant discussion i
can't wait to dig into this
our guest today is elizabeth colbert
elizabeth colbert thank you so much for
um joining us
on metaphysical milkshake you know rayne
and i are big fans of yours we both
absolutely loved the sixth extinction
your
uh previous book i have to say i can't
wait for the sequel the seventh
extinction
it's gonna be amazing what was great
about that book it was like this deep
dive into um the uh the so-called
anthropo posey and anthropocene
i think anthro anthropocene anthropo
anthropocene yeah it's pronounced
differently depending on which side of
the atlantic you're on actually what is
it on our side of the atlantic
it's usually pronounced the anthropocene
on our side of the atlantic
but if i wanted to be like fancy and
british and sound smart what would i say
you'd say anthropocene for our more
ignorant
listeners and you know who you are you
all know exactly who you are
explain to us what exactly is the
anthropocene
era technically it's an epoch
not an era and geologists are very
are very persnickety about their
geological time periods
and the anthropocene would and people
do debate we can talk about this um and
when exactly it started some people say
with the start of the industrial
revolution some people would say much
more recently
more like um when we started dropping
you know
doing above ground nuclear testing
but it represents this idea that we have
entered a new geological time period
where
humans are the
or a dominant geological force
doesn't like we're we're like exerting
our will
over the planet yes i mean a lot of it
we didn't do consciously for example um
you know changing the climate we didn't
really set out to do that
but we did it anyway and we're affecting
all aspects
of nature uh climate geology
biology weather yeah i mean there are
all sorts of
you know astonishing statistics that
suggest that we have become
a very dominant force for example humans
you know with our bulldozers and etc we
move around
as much earth and sediment as
all of the world's major rivers which
you know is a huge geological
force so that's that's just one uh
you know one measure of our of our
impact we
in our fertilizer plants we
produce as much we fix as much nitrogen
and it's a little bit technical we're
not going to go into exactly what
nitrogen fixing is but we fix as much
nitrogen
as all terrestrial ecosystems combined
so you know the list kind of goes on and
on these are pretty
pretty big deals we emit a hundred times
more co2 every
every year than volcanoes do and
volcanoes used to be the major
you know outputters of of co2 into the
atmosphere so these are just some of the
ways that we
are now have have become
um the prevailing force on planet earth
and i just tweeted the other day that i
read that one out of every three
in your book i read one out of every
three co2 molecules in the atmosphere
was
put there by humans yes exactly that's
another
indicator yeah i realized that i did not
credit you in my tweet
and i apologize for that i forgive you
but we are gonna give this book such
twitter love under a white sky
the nature of the future i loved it i
thought it was fascinating
i loved every story every example i want
you to talk to us about the book and
then we'll get into some of the
kind of bigger meatier questions that
underlie
what the book is about but one of the
ironies of the anthropocene is
how often humans they try and fix one
ecological problem
and then they invite a new one and this
happens time
and time again and in this incredibly
well-traveled researched
book you go from example to example to
example
um we were hoping you could start with
the one around the
the chicago river and the ship canal
in lake michigan because it it opens up
so many questions and issues
yeah sure so that's that's a very very
vivid one and as you say
it opens up the book to give this short
version
what happened was chicago grew up along
the chicago river anyone who's been to
chicago knows that
um it's sort of a you know it's a modest
river
but um it's key to the city's history
because the city used it
to dispose of all of its waste as it was
growing up all of its human waste and
then as the incredible stockyards
of chicago grew up all of its all the
waste from the stockyards
and so the river um it was said that the
river was so
thick with filth that a a chicken could
walk across it without ever getting its
feet wet
um so it was you know so this was it
you know this was just gross but beyond
being just gross
um it was a real public health hazard
because
the river was flowing east into lake
michigan
and chicago was also drawing its
drinking water it still draws its
drinking water from lake michigan so
you you can kind of do the math on that
so towards
around the turn of the 20th century
chicago decided to
do something about this problem and what
it decided to do
was to actually reverse the flow of the
chicago river
and this was one of the biggest
construction projects of its era
and it involved digging this canal the
sanitarian ship canal
that then connected the chicago
river so instead of flowing into the
great lakes it was now flowing into the
mississippi drainage basin and so now
chicago's waste
was flowing west and ultimately ending
up
actually in the gulf of mexico problem
solved everybody was happy
thank you elizabeth it was wonderful to
have you on the podcast
[Laughter]
exactly no it's true that the
missourians were not we're not happy
about
about this at all to think of being you
know
chicago's waste flowing past it um but
that's what happened chicago did it
when it opened the canal there was a
headline in the new york times and i i'm
not getting exactly right but it was
something like
uh water in the chicago river resembles
liquid again
i mean it was it was a joke basically
so so chicago does this despite you know
missourians complaints
um and what no one has really thought
that much about
is now we have connected these two great
drainage basins the great lakes drainage
basin and the mississippi drainage basin
which previously were separate not very
separate you know
you could walk from one to the other but
if you were aquatic you couldn't get in
to you couldn't move from one basin to
the
other and over the course of the 20th
century
both the mississippi basin and the great
lakes basin became
highly invaded ecosystems and
so all sorts of species wreaking all
sorts of havoc on
in both basins and then you got also
this ability to cross from one to the
other so
around the turn of the 20th century it
was decided uh oh
you know this is a bad idea so after
having reversed the chicago river
now part of the river is electrified to
try to keep
these species on their respective sides
of what used to be this great divide
and part two of your book those species
are there's algae clogging
the rivers of the mississippi basin so
they bring in
asian carp four different species to eat
the algae
and this is the most invasive fish in
the history of
the planet earth and they're terrified
that the asian carp is gonna make its
way up the mississippi
through all their little tributaries to
the chicago river up into lake michigan
and essentially like like seven chinese
brothers swallowing the ocean
uh just destroy the ecosystem of the
great lakes
yeah exactly so these like these
electric barriers
are supposed to be keeping asian carp
from moving
from the mississippi system which as you
say they've really
taken over you know um into the great
lakes
and no one really is
confident no one really wants to rely on
that
so they're actually the army corps of
engineers is planning another series of
barriers
that would have bubbles and noise it was
described to me as a
disco barrier um a sort of
supplemental set of barriers that would
be built further
i guess south you would say so sort of
down river
uh to try to dissuade the fish
that much more but you know all these
are obviously
um somewhat ad hoc
stop gap measures
brain you and i huge star wars fans
right am i right it's true none bigger
and that's why i am wearing my
fandom with pride with my new star wars
rings from enso rings
these are the coolest silicone rings
i've ever seen the designs are amazing
they feel great on i've got five of them
on my hand right now because that's how
i roll
you know where i first saw these enso
rings was at a comic-con i love going to
comic-cons
and i saw kind of the hippest of nerds
wearing enso rings and i realized rings
don't need to be made out of metal
yeah especially if you're a writer like
me you can't have a big heavy metal
thing on your fingers
i love these things they're so
lightweight they're so
cool and there's six of them i've got
right now on my hand the mandalorian on
my thumb i got darth vader in my first
finger i got grogu in my middle finger
r2d2
right here and my ring finger c-3po and
even
i got an extra one here for the
stormtrooper they're all made in the usa
at their facility in utah you can choose
your favorite or
do what i did buy them all together in a
limited edition collector's box
trust us you're going to love the star
wars collection from enso rings
two don't miss out order yours today go
to ensorings.com
that's ensorings.com get
free shipping with the code star wars
that's star wars remember ensorings.com
hey rain fun fact did you know the first
oranges weren't
orange they were green what another fun
fact for you
did you know the letter q doesn't appear
in the name
of any state in the united states yeah
what about minoquota
i got a personal fun fact did you know
that i'm not wearing pants right now
that's disgusting but i also have a
personal fun fact and this is for real
i have an extra rib
here's a not so fun fact americans
overspend on insurance by
21 billion dollars every year and you my
friends deserve all the facts
and that's where the zebra can help you
the zebra compares car and home
insurance quotes
from every major provider in under five
minutes
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision for you
all for free it's the fastest way to
find the right coverage at the right
price
all from a provider you can trust in
fact the zebra
saves shoppers an average of 920
on home and car insurance combined and
that
is a very fun fact let me tell you i
could have used the zebra
when uh i was on our family rv trip and
broken down
in the middle of nowhere for two days
but it's not too late now
so you can get all the facts in one
place start comparing quotes for free
today
by visiting the zebra.com
milkshake that's the zebra.com
milkshake so just to be clear
we [ __ ] up the chicago river
and rather than actually stop [ __ ] it
up
we just reversed the course of the river
but then that created another problem
which is all these weeds and algaes that
got in the way of the
of the boats like rain was saying and so
we had to deal with the weeds and the
algae so we thought oh we'll just throw
some asian carp in there they'll eat the
weed
and the algae that took care of the
wheat and the algae but now we have all
these asian carp
and so we have to figure out what to do
about the asian carp
so the answer was let's just electrify
the river
and this becomes essentially the theme
of under a white sky
which is that throughout much of human
history uh as you as you rightly say in
the
anthropocene era which is how i say it
rain well said
epoch i'm sorry did i say era i don't
wanna please don't send me emails people
the story of of humanity has precisely
been
this like attempt to impose our will
and to control nature and then that has
had obviously these devastating
consequences this control of nature you
um is both described as bioengineering
and geoengineering can you give the
listeners a description of those two
concepts
well no
i'm not sure exactly what you mean i
have to be frank i mean
i mean well i like the cane toads are
being bio-engineered
uh through crispr to be less poisonous
okay genetic genetic genetically
engineered but i would say anything that
has to do with
changing the biology of something would
be bioengineering
what do i know i'm i'm a dumb i'm a
sitcom actor
but geo engineering being like the
the what you end the book on and the
title of the book under a white sky
the option to help curtail for a limited
amount of time
uh the effects of climate change by
putting some kind of reflective aerosol
in the atmosphere
that would be more um i guess
geo just because it has to do with uh
earth and
temperatures and uh climate
and non-living species yes exactly that
has
that is called that's called
geoengineering i mean
or it's called somewhat more soothingly
it's
sometimes called solar radiation
management
um so yes we we can
we have now you know we have a capacity
or at least in theory
to rewrite um the biology of the planet
using technologies like crispr so to
just gene edit
g-net we could gene edit ourselves
theoretically not
probably not uh those of us who are
already
you know grown but are kids and we can
gene edit you know theoretically again
just about everything on earth and we
also have the capacity to
transform the stratosphere once again at
least in theory we could
um as you are alluding to the idea
behind
you know solar geoengineering is we
would shoot some kind of reflective
stuff into the stratosphere and you know
control the climate
that way i feel like i've seen this
movie you know what i'm saying
it never works out that movie usually
stars gerard butler
yeah it's always gerard park it ends
with the death of like
hundreds of millions of people but not
gerard and that's the importance he
survives he's a survivor
have there been any successes i mean you
go around the world and
and there's these nightmare scenarios of
mankind
meddling with species and importing
creatures and plants and
and moving rivers and affecting the
atmosphere and it's just
it's just pretty awful has humanity ever
successfully
done bio or geo en engineering
well i mean i think the question is you
know successfully for whom
i guess is the question right or what i
mean you know yeah
look of course we've completely
transformed the world and there's
you know more people on the planet than
ever before
so on some level we've been you know
just extraordinarily successful
um agriculture you know feeds
you know 7.8 billion people some a lot
better than others but you know
uh that's a lot of people and a lot more
people than have ever been on the planet
before
so it's been an incredibly successful
project that's exactly you know why
we're in the anthropocene
um you know but in the process
you know even ag you know take
agriculture which you could say is a
you know pretty big deal um
and and feeds us all well something was
you know displaced in in the process of
that it's been
you know very good for humanity but it
it hasn't been so good for anything that
lived in that you know forest that got
cut down
so we could plant soy or corn or
whatever the hell it is
so you know you do have to ask the
question whose pers
whose perspective are you taking in some
ways this comes to the
the heart of the matter right which is
and rain and i talk about this
all the time because it stresses us out
as people who are
you know environmentally conscious and
the this larger question of
is it just too late is it just too late
to do anything
about the environment i mean is it too
late to slow down
climate change is it too late to kind of
reverse
um the the destruction that we have
wrought on our planet
um and is it just time to kind of
get used to uh this
future that's about to come so in other
words are we
are we putting all of our resources into
trying to stop a problem that is no
longer stoppable
instead of uh focusing on
making us more likely to survive
this future that is about to come and if
i feel like
in many ways you fall into that latter
category
right because i mean one of the things
that you do write about in this book is
the the attempt by people not to
um slow down climate change but to
radically alter uh you know the the very
sort of nature of our of our planet in
order
to you know fix and
what is now kind of an unfixable problem
it's too late to undo the climate change
we've already accomplished which is you
know a significant amount of climate
change um
you know we've already probably raised
average
global temperatures by you know roughly
two degrees fahrenheit that's you know
nothing to sneeze at and we're seeing
all sorts of
sorts of impacts and the only way we
could
you know fix that or reverse that is to
do something like geoengineering
um but you know there's a difference
between
throwing up our hands and i mean i'll
take the example of climate change
because i think it's kind of top of mind
for a lot of people right now though
although it's not the only issue i talk
about in the book
um you know there's there's like you
know bad outcomes and then there's
you know disastrous you know billions
killed outcomes and we still do have a
choice here and we still have a lot of
choices so
um there's a kind of a saying
in you know climate circles if such
things exist
that what we need to do is you know
manage the unavoidable
and avoid the unmanageable and that is
still
you know possible but it gets more and
more difficult every day that goes by as
we
just continue to pour sear two into the
atmosphere so i feel that if you boil
all of this down
it comes down to the book of genesis
from the bible
which is man shall have dominion over
nature and subdue
the creatures and subdue subdue the
earth something like that i'm i'm i'm
vaguely misquoting but
god did a better job when he said it
yeah what would it have been like if in
the book of
genesis it said like if man shall be
caretakers of the earth
or stewards of the growth of nature
or you know but this idea of dominion
and subduing
you know yeah was probably super
important for humanity when we were
starting out you know the first
couple millennium on this planet we
needed to dominate we needed to subdue
in order to survive we probably couldn't
have done it
otherwise however that way of looking at
our relationship
with nature which according to a lot of
people have been kind of
divinely prescribed has really
gotten us here don't you think isn't it
isn't this
about a complete and total overhaul and
re-imagination
about our relationship of not being over
nature
but part of nature well
i mean i don't know if we needed you
know um
genesis to set us on this path
um but uh
you know i think that one of the
problems and it's a pretty profound
problem and this is the problem i would
really say at the heart
of of my book is you know it's
it's nice to say in 2021
well we really ought to start living in
harmony with nature
but it's living not in harmony with
nature
that has allowed us to be you know 7.8
billion
going very rapidly on 7.9 billion people
and it's nothing that you can suddenly
say oh we really ought to
you know go back to a way we lived you
know
either pre-genesis or whatever past you
want to
look back toward where humans were much
less of a force on planet earth there
were a lot fewer of us
and they didn't you know so so we didn't
you know it's pre-agriculture we didn't
have to
uh
feed and clothe and house you know a lot
of people and a lot of people
who should be fed and housed in clothes
better than they are now you know so so
we have a pretty
big um we're not really in a position to
go
you know it's nice to talk and sort of
hand wave about living
in harmony with nature but it's not
clear to me
exactly how a modern uh industrialized
society upon which
billions of people depend can do that
ladies and gentlemen and i'm speaking
mostly to the gentleman this episode is
sponsored by
blue chew say it with us blue
chew it's fun how it rolls off the lips
that's what she said blue chew is making
waves and bringing more confidence
to the bedroom by offering chewable
tablets that can help men get stronger
and longer lasting
erections who doesn't want stronger and
longer lasting
erections answer nobody doesn't want
that blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but
in chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger
erections and it combats all forms of
edd that's erectile dysfunction for
those of you who are not in the know
blue chew is an online prescription
service so there's no visits to the
doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet little package so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and here is a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew
free when you use our promo code
milkshake
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code milkshake to receive your
first month
free and we thank bluechu for sponsoring
our podcast
this podcast is brought to you by better
help
listeners is there something interfering
with your happiness or is something
preventing you from achieving your goals
oh yeah yeah lots and lots of things why
do you ask
rain well listen um mental health is
something that i've spoken a lot about
it's something really important to me
and a lot of time what gets in the way
is anxiety
depression better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 48 hours
this is not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling
and financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living
a happier life today reza wow
okay well then so visit betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they're now recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
there's a special offer from
metaphysical milkshake listeners so
listen up you get
10 off your first month at better help
if you use the code milkshake so that's
betterhelp.com
milkshake so
elizabeth can i call you elizabeth you
may
elizabeth can i call you betty no
what is what is your preferred nickname
betsy i don't
want to say it's my preferred nickname
but it's what people call me
all right betsy listen up when i was a
kid i religiously watched star trek
about there's about seven or eight
episodes
where they beam down to a planet to find
these bucolic
people living in harmony with nature
tilling the soil having
animals you know picking fruits and
wearing togas or or what
or frocks or burlap sacks or something
like that and then
and then but they're getting weird
readings or whatnot and they go
behind the scenes and they find like
all this technology like under the grass
mat of their hut
is like computers and and we realize
that like back in the day
they used to uh have all of this
technology but it brought them to the
brink of war or disaster or ruined their
planet or environment or
or what have you and now they've kind of
set that beside them behind
them and they're choosing to live a
different kind of
you know peaceful agrarian lifestyle or
something like that and
i love those episodes in reading your
book that's what it made me think about
because i thought about what
another gigantic question that underlies
your work is like
where are we headed we're certainly
headed for an ecological
and environmental catastrophe with
climate change and
and it's ensuing uh repercussions
but where where does humanity go
200 years from now 500 years from now i
know
this is you're a reporter and you
haven't been there and seen it and
interviewed the folks but
asking you also as a thinker in this
realm like
where do you see us going do you see us
potentially being like
one of those star trek civilizations you
know i don't see us
doing that willingly although you know
many there are many narratives that um
you know which are fairly utopian star
trek as utopian narrative
but it's quite possible that we'll get
there you know somewhat you know kicking
and screaming
i think that is quite possible i guess
the
problem and the and the worry
is you know what happens between here
and there so i'll give you another
you know example several billion people
are now alive you know the three of us
let's just put it that way and many
billions of others because of
synthetic fertilizers which were
invented in the
right around the start of world war one
and now feed
you know two or three billion people
so you could say well let's let's go
back you know let's go
back to that bucolic moment when we were
you know picking fruit in before
but that require you know if you go back
to the arab of force and third
synthetic fertilizers you know
that consigns a lot of people to
starvation so you know we're obviously
not
doing that willingly and i i honestly
don't think we should do that willingly
but you know will we get to a point
where
the current way of doing things is is
unsustainable
and in in some either you know
slow or fast way that's made apparent to
us
i i do think that's quite possible when
you look out you know over the horizon
of you know what we would consider the
sort of foreseeable future
but a lot of it i do want to say to not
be too sort of nihilistic
a lot of it does depend on choices that
are being made right now
i can't say i see them being made
particularly well
but they could be made better well okay
well that's an interesting point because
you actually do
touch on this in the book which is okay
so
if we have the ability to um
fix our damaging control over nature
by controlling nature a little bit more
well what what ought we to save you know
like
right at this moment like what do you
think um we need to focus on
first and foremost and and sort of what
are the
moral and ethical implications of
choosing you know one species over
another or choosing
one you know focus over another
you know like step one would obviously
be like
you know global ethics for dummies or
whatever you know step one would
obviously be
for certainly for
very wealthy countries like our own to
um you know really dramatically
reduce their carbon emissions and
probably really dramatically
reduce our consumption of all kinds you
know we're just consuming
way way more and if everyone on the
planet consumed at the level that we do
you know we would have already hit that
wall uh decades ago
so you know if you if you realize it's
sort of what you're doing
if universalized would be
completely unsustainable then then you
kind of have a responsibility it seems
to me
to reevaluate that now that you know
we're going to see
some of these issues play out even over
the next
couple of years or maybe over the next
couple months you know
is there going to be any climate change
um
legislation passed by the us congress
you know are we going to see
things that actually impinge on people's
lives in any way or is that just
politically so toxic
you know that that's not going to happen
i don't know the answer to that it's
actually a pretty interesting
moment to see where things are heading
rain this reminds me of that thing you
were saying um
a while ago about how the word
environmentalism
uh like the definition of it is changed
now
right i mean it used to mean like
environmentalists was somebody who was
focused on preventing climate change and
maybe now like
an environmentalist is somebody who
promotes
like active reversal the environmental
movement
really started with author rachel carson
and her book silent spring
and uh she was like the grand mama
environmentalist you know in terms of an
activist environmentalist
and yeah you're right back then 60s 70s
80s even environmentalism was about
preserving what's there let's save the
redwoods let's save the whales let's
stop uh you know construction bulldozing
forests or what have you
um but with increased control uh
you know enacted by humanity time and
time again
uh i think environmentalism needs a
redefinition
rachel carson said the control of nature
is a phrase conceived in arrogance
born of the neanderthal age there's that
word neanderthal again
of biology and philosophy when it was
supposed that nature
exists for the convenience of man
but i would say rachel 20 21 we have to
redefine
environmentalism we have to do whatever
we can
and this may require us using crispr on
various animal species
it may involve us like genetically
modifying
and breeding coral to save coral it may
involve us
spraying an aerosol in the stratosphere
to reflect heat
and give us another like 10 years to
kind of get our [ __ ] together down on
planet earth
being an environmentalist might mean
being undertaking um increased control
yeah yeah it's crazy yeah no this is a
huge
i mean you have identified a huge sort
of
schism i suppose in the environmental
movement and increasingly
you know there are all sorts of
of wheels and subwheels here you know i
mean for example for
for a long time it was considered to be
um you know not a not a good idea to
talk about ways that that we were going
to adapt to climate change you know
let's not talk about
how we're going to adapt to climate
change because that just is going to
prevent people from focusing on what we
really need to do which is
stop emitting and try to minimize
climate change well now
too late that argument isn't happening
anymore because it's very clear we're
going to be having to adapt to climate
change exactly we have to try to
minimize climate change but we
also have to adapt because so much
climate change is already
baked into the system so all these
debates
things are sort of creeping along and
climate change is a real challenge to a
lot of the
you know basic tenets of the
environmental
you know classic sort of environmental
movement because you can't keep things
the same
even if you you know walled off part of
the world and said let's
this is a habitat for you know x and
we're gonna just
not touch it no one go there just leave
it alone
well the climate's still changing around
you so you know
that's not gonna work so all of these
questions
um i don't want to say they have to be
rethought
but they're they're everything has a lot
of the basic just leave it alone
um thrust of the environmental movement
is definitely being challenged and i
myself
emma leave it alone environmentalists at
heart you know
i think i i i think as much of the
planet as possible
should be left alone even though i
understand that it's going to
you know be be changing underneath us
you know and ed wilson
the famous naturalist has this you know
half earth a book called half earth
where he talks about we should be
setting aside
half the earth for other species now
that half the earth
you know i don't see us doing that but i
think it's a good idea
and that half the earth is still going
to change owing to climate change
among other things but it would allow
creatures to sort of
evolve and as many as possible you know
some of
some creatures will migrate some will
adapt
you know some will evolve and some will
drop out i mean those are those are all
going to happen
but the more space you give them you
know the more
likely it is that they'll get through um
but even so it's impossible to just sort
of say well we're just leaving things
alone
yeah i i read an uh an opinion piece
today in the guardian uh by erin
brockovich
it wasn't really an opinion piece it's a
science piece
about the decrease in sperm uh
production
by the human male and the way she wrote
about it is like
this is next to climate change this is
this is huge
like 50 years from now 100 years from
now we could have zero sperm
well maybe that will solve our problem
well that's on the bright side but
that's what i thought when i read it at
first i was like well
would that be such a bad thing if all of
a sudden that's why i have so many kids
man that's that's the whole point i know
i'm trying you know he does how many
kids do you have he's a breeder
um by last count uh like i want to say
in 34 i don't know
you literally have four though right
five four i literally have four yeah he
has four yeah
but uh two of them were mine but jessica
and i will talk to you it's a long story
[Music]
uh elizabeth this book has given us so
much to think about honestly like
you know these ideas were always in the
back of my mind but but i've never
really
thought about it in this way and i mean
i gotta be honest with you i'm like i'm
a
i'm a believer i'm a disciple i i think
yeah
yes we need to we need to even
uh further manipulate our environment
and nature we need to
control it even more despite the fact
that it's most definitely going to end
in some gerard butler movie like
that's the guaranteed
[Music]
we like to end these conversations with
what we call the lightning round
if you could jurassic world style
bring any one extinct animal back
what would it be you know i have a real
fondest for the great awk
i'm gonna go with the great ock so many
animals that have the title great in
them
they're not really that great a great
dane
it's a very good dane well we don't we
don't
since none of us has met a great oc but
you can see them in some natural history
museums they're really beautiful birds
name something a lot of people like but
you can't stand
oh my god um mounds
bars my wife loves mounds bars
i mean like why would you eat coconut in
a in a candy bar it makes no sense
anyway
what's the silliest fear that you have i
have so many fears it's like fear of
fears
fear on top of fears fears that i don't
haven't that i have too many fears how's
that
yeah we shouldn't ask this question of
an environmental
reporter that seems like a bad idea yeah
seriously that's unfair
it's unfair what is one skill you wish
you had
i really wish i could draw i've been
trying to draw and i'm really bad
what emotion do you wish you could
control better
hmm fear
describe your soul in 10 words or less
oh wow a seething cauldron
what's something that most people don't
know about you
i have to pass on that one because what
would anyone know about me yeah i would
say what a fearful person you are
no they know i read this book it feels
like you're not afraid of anything
well my husband says that they're two
me's there's the real me and then
there's
me the reporter yeah and then and i'm
pretty fearless when i'm
reporting but which one does he like
better very fearful yeah
good question yeah what book has had the
greatest impact on your life and why
in a weird sort of way uh
it was uh faust gerta's faust
which led me to learn german which led
me to go to germany which led me to
become a journalist so i guess i'd have
to say
in a really roundabout way that had the
biggest impact on me
how do you think you will die maybe like
um on an ice floe or something because i
i've been to greenland to this place
where they supposedly
let the old people off on the isil and i
thought that was actually kind of a good
way to go if i could arrange it actually
from what i've read
freezing to death is the best way to go
i think so
i think it might be drowning is
supposedly horrible
painful and horrific because your your
lungs think they're breathing so you're
breathing in and out water
and you can stay alive for several
minutes then why why does everybody say
drowning is like peaceful is it just
they're punking us right it's their
pumpkin they're daring it's like no
it's fine go ahead drown it's fine
what's one
eye-opening experience that you think
every person should have
i think and this does bring us back to
going off on an ice floe
one experience that i've had that really
changed my life was
being on top of the greenland ice sheet
but i can't really recommend that
everyone shoop to the top of the
greenland ice sheet because i don't
think that's a good idea
but in theory i think that would be a
very good experience
i was there last last year um over by
i went to elulasat and over by
kangaluswak
and and took a helicopter up onto the
ice sheet it was
it was amazing and then finally
elizabeth
what is your life's big question
yeah what are we doing here
elizabeth colbert the book is called
under a white
sky uh it is fascinating and frightening
and definitely mind-altering thank you
so much
for uh speaking with us on metaphysical
milkshake thank you so much
thank you it's fun
wow what a fascinating discussion she's
amazing uh what a brilliant to think
about
mind uh yeah so much to unpack there
it's just it's just fantastic
i mean i love this idea like you were
saying in your in your conversation with
her about how like
the very term environmentalism has to
mean something different now right it
used to mean
preserving nature and now it means like
reversing
you know the problems that we've had
like we have to we have to manipulate
the environment for good yeah it used to
be i i don't wear deodorant i like to
take hikes i drive an electric car
and i recycle uh and now it's gonna be
so much more than that you know it's
gonna
it's gonna mean taking active steps i
think
to manipulate for the positive
um our our living breathing world in
some way what
are you ready to go there reza are you
ready i think i think i have to like
this is she elizabeth is telling us that
what this is what we got to do
we got to manipulate nature both in our
own lives and of course on the on the
grants
what are you going to do to manipulate
nature well um
let's see i can um i could figure out
how to breed my chickens to babysit my
kids
that would be that would be something
well that's gonna take some genetic
modification you're gonna have to use
crispr
to kind of clone little chickens that
have um
the the the smartest chickens you know
too oh yeah i'm not gonna have a dumb
chicken babysit my kids rain
jesus of course i'm that's i'm gonna do
the same thing with my pigs i'm gonna uh
what's your what's your plan
i'm gonna use crispr to have my pigs uh
learn to make me breakfast
what do you think is that possible they
don't have opposable thumbs
it might be a problem but and i'm not
sure if that's how crispr works
you know i've listened to like 27
podcasts on crispr i still don't
really understand what's going on well
that's better than me i've been
pretending this entire podcast like i
know what you're talking about but i
actually don't
as you know every week we reach out to
our audience and say hey what do you
think we love your questions we'd love
your comments we'd like your life's big
questions
and in this case we got a question that
is very relevant
to the topic at hand let's roll the
audio tape i think religion
is ever more necessary in the
contemporary times and it's not that
we have a dominion over our nature by
our choosing
but a god-given bounty
that we can either use
or misuse um it's been told
in baha'i writings that
every created thing
[Music]
um is there for the advancement of human
soul
i don't know where that is exactly but i
can you know find it
um and
there could be a chance that i'm wrong
as a person with what i interpret
in the world but
such things as divine revelation
meaning the expression of the divine
will
is not wrong and that's how we are able
to
distinguish between right and wrong okay
all right interesting interesting so it
sounds like uh a couple of observations
sounds like one of my uh so i'm a member
of the baha'i faith one of my baha'i
brothers uh called in thank you very
much for the call
what are your sleep here one of my
sleepier baha'i brothers who
was very very so close to that
microphone i could hear
every little detail about how the saliva
moved around his mouth
but uh some interesting thoughts in
there
it's this whole thing of religion this
is what we talked about this whole time
right is that
this whole dominion over nature thing
starts with this idea that
you know people who follow a lot of
different religions think that somehow
that dominion is
divinely mandated he calls it a bounty
well i guess
i would hear it in the opposite way like
we we
certainly here in the old testament you
know thou shalt have dominion
over nature but what does that mean
because there's plenty of other
religious traditions
you know monotheistic and otherwise
where
humanity is called upon to have a very
different relationship
with nature than dominion over it
um and it at the end i think what he was
hinting at was like
if nature is an expression of god if
nature is an expression of the divine
and the divine will
then we need to live in harmony
with that and not try and subdue
control limit and uh and exert our will
over it maybe i'm reading that into the
question but that's kind of what i got
like you're you're behind is that is
that what what the baha'i teachings
about the relationship between humanity
and nature
in the baha'i faith nature is an
expression of god's of god's will and
god's beauty
so we're caretakers we're not
controllers um and there are you know
prohibitions in the baha'i faith for
instance
against uh animals becoming extinct
we should not allow animals to become
extinct because
they are a creation of god so anytime
you've got some like
kind of great giant awk and it's
there's no more giant ox on the planet
you know
that that is that is a crime against
nature itself this is a beautiful thing
that
evolved through the process of evolution
again baha'is believe in the
total harmony of science and religion
that you know
god's you know igniting creative will
through the power of science and
evolution created the great ark
and what a tragedy and travesty it is to
let a species die in that way
no see that's interesting so in islam
it's a slightly different especially
within the sufi tradition that
i follow it's not so much that nature is
created by god
it's that nature is god god
is in and of himself creation and so
anything that
exists exists only in so far as it
shares in the only thing that exists
and so yeah it's not so much dominion
it's
that you recognize the divinity in
nature and then of course
you know the correct behavior is to
treat
nature as though it is developed so
obviously that keeps you from exploiting
it
and to treat nature as if it is divine
and is as
if it is alive and it is in so many ways
depending on how you define
life thank you farzine farzin
and uh next time just uh back off the
mic a little bit thanks buddy
just a tiny bit just a half inch
what about you dear listener do you have
any ideas about how to manipulate nature
uh for good as opposed to for bad
write us call us talk to us call rezza
at home
uh write us on uh social at uh reza
aslan
rayne wilson at metaphysical milkshake
let us know your life's
questions and we might explore them in a
future
episode also let me know if you're
available to babysit and
remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen to
your podcast you can also subscribe to
the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel and then you can watch
us have a conversation instead of just
listening to us
yeah it's really magical watching us
uh otherwise we will see you next week
assuming there will be
a next week let's hope
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane
mick dimaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle
original music by jeff tang
reza i think we need to count our sperm
all right let's do it
oh i thought you meant right now oh
that's disgusting